alors on avait c'est un petit peu la
lumière on bouge pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il le fait bien là avec ces ions du ray
charles trenet oui il ne fait pas
seulement bien regarder parfait bien
alors c'est une interview sans la bouche
et je peux pas parler voilà dont vous ne
parlez pas c'est pas de blabla du tout
là et vous allez répondre avec des
gestes dont je vous posais des questions
et vous allez répondre avec des avec des
gestes prévention parce que moi j'ai une
grande bavarde d'accord alors vous vous
avez justement parce que vous êtes une
bavarde donc le matin les premiers
exemples comme ça le matin vous vous
réveillez vous vous regarder dans la
glace
tout va bien
j'adore s'étale dans le bus on les
oblige pas à vous pouvez dire tout ce
que vous voulez vous mais ça repose une
interview sans la bouche voyait alors le
matin vous vous réveillez tout va mal
vous êtes dans la rue vous conduisez
vous êtes dans l'art avec une copine
dans une voiture et un camion poubelle
qui vous bloquent la rue et vous êtes
pressés vous avez un rendez vous vous
ouvrez la fenêtre
elle a parlé en cas brawn et
elle l'a fait ou cela on essaye quoi
vous amenez votre votre fille à l'école
et vous partez de l'école vous êtes un
peu triste de la laisser là un peu
triste de vous voir partir et elle et
vous la voyez à travers la ville voulu
vous la regardez à travers la vie de
vous le faites quoi
d'accord vous vous êtes à un feu rouge
dans la voiture votre copine voyez un
super mec au feu rouge
parlant bien coiffé mois un chèque je
tape
votre numéro
vous allez bouffer dans un resto la
dernière fois qu'on a dîné ensemble
c'est un super bon je voulais vous dire
vraiment la bouffe
ouais je fais le calme bon mais là la
bouffe et ce soir là la bouffe est
infect vite quoi aux patrons
way et il a une panne sexuelle vous lui
dites quoi
avant
tout ce que vous faites ah
et si ça marche pas
ah ouais vous essayerez à vous essayez
rien d'autre
oui bon
enfin j'ai plein de stratagèmes et
bien c'est très bien je l'applaudis
pour être sûr de ne rien rater le lit
nos latitudes abonnez vous il mettait un
peu de bleu